[Electronic music]
(DF-, DF-, DF-...)
(DFTBA) [echoes]
(DFT- ... DF-)
(A-A-A-...) [stutters]
(DFTBA) [echoes]
(DF- .... D-)
Don't forget that brains attract.
Darling, fetch the battle axe!
Decepticons fear this brilliant autobot.
Do fish take baths a lot?
Dogs frequently take back apologies.
Dreadful feudal treachery breeds atrocities.
Darkened forests take bravery away -
DFTB, DFTB, DFTBA.
Doctor Freud's topic became afflicting.
Damn Facebook, too bloody addicting!
I came down for the baby's arrival,
But the dead father's thoughts became archival.
Drunk fish try breathing air,
Debutante's fame tarnished by affairs,
Delano fears to be afraid,
DFTB, DFTB, DFTBA.
I don't know what you mean when you say -
Please explain:
What is DFTB?
I don't know what you mean when you say -
Please explain:
What is DFTBA?
DFTB, DFTB, DFTBA,
DFTB, DFTB, DFTBA!
It's so damn fine to be alive,
Until your dorky, farting, turdface brother arrives.
Difficult financial times bring apocalypse,
Danes fear the burning acropolis.
Donate for the blood associations,
Don't for the beaux's admirations!
Delilah's fruitcake triggers belly-ache;
DFTB, DFTB, DFTBA.
Dead frogs teach bored anatomists,
Delightful fans that blithely assist.
Duel for the best acronym,
A dark force to boldly apprehend.
Dastardly farmers took Bessie away,
But she was destined for the burger anyway.
Distro falling through bleak Autumn,
Don't forget to be awesome!
I don't know what you mean when you say -
Please explain:
What is DFTB?
I don't know what you mean when you say -
Please explain:
What is DFTB
A?
(DFTB, DFTB, DFTBA,)
DFTB, DFTB, DFTBA!
DFTB, DFTB, DFTBA,
(Oh, and Hank...)
(Like it says on my friend Katie's arm...)
(Don't forget to be awesome.)
(Oh, and Hank...)
(Like it says on my friend Katie's arm...)
(Don't forget to be awesome.)
(Oh, and Hank...)
(Like it says on my friend Katie's arm...)
(Don't forget to be awe-) [stutters]
I don't know what you mean when you say -
Please explain:
What is DFTB?
I don't know what you mean when you say -
Please explain:
What is DFTB-
I don't know what
(DFTB, DFTB, DFTBA,)
you mean when you say -
(DFTB, DFTB, DFTBA!)
Please explain:
(DFTB, DFTB, DFTBA,)
What is DFTB?
(DFTB, DFTB, DFTBA!)
I don't know what
(DFTB, DFTB, DFTBA,)
you mean when you say -
(DFTB, DFTB, DFTBA!)
Please explain:
(DFTB, DFTB, DFTBA,)
What is DF
(DFTB, DFTB, DFTBA!)
TBA?
[Music fades]
(Dandelions fly through blue air.)
As you might expect, that was not one hundred
percent my work.
Thank you to all of the Nerdfighters who suggested DFTBA acronyms,
and all of the Nerdfighters who illustrated DFTBA acronyms,
but most of all, most importantly,
the most important person of this entire project was Michael Aranda!
So, I wrote about your rap lyrics, and I was like,
"I don't know how to turn this into a song,"
so I instant-messaged Michael Aranda, and he was like:
That guy's so cool. You need to go subscribe
to him ... right now. Go subscribe to him.
And, I will see all of you very soon.
DFTB, DFTB, DFTBA!
I spat on my camera...